what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today we will be
talking about all the latest events in
the seven deadly sins story including
bonds new powerup the sacred treasure
curry juice which we have now finally
seen in action I am going to explain how
bonds sacred treasure affects his
overall strength and power and how the
unique abilities of his sacred treasure
might impact the rest of the story let's
get into it if you enjoyed the seven
deadly sins content on this channel you
can leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell you can also follow us on Twitter
and Instagram at anime opera or all the
latest news and updates
finally this video will be discussing
the latest in the seven deadly sins
stories so manga spoilers will be
included please proceed with caution you
have been warned chapter 316 begins with
information about the Lord's grace in
Deraa the giant Lovecraftian in Deraa
that the demon king has summoned from
the demon realm and that all the sins
aside from a leotis are currently
fighting the cover page for this chapter
reveals that the Lord's grace in Deraa
is a form taken by a member of the ten
commandments
after this member sacrificed six of
their seven demon hearts we also learned
that this Endura is the most powerful of
its kind and it has the highest combat
class out of all the legendary in their
beasts now it makes sense why this
particular Endura was summoned by the
demon king although now i'm wondering
which former member of the ten
commandments became this Endura the
former members of the ten commandments
that we know of who could potentially
have become this indira are calm adiós
Aaron ACK and zan Oh Aaron Atkins II
know are said to be dead so if that's
true and unless there are more former
members that we still don't know about
the most likely candidate for D and era
is calm adios Cal Maggio's had fought as
the piety of the ten commandments in the
holy war from 3,000 years ago but he was
defeated by droll and gloxinia with the
help of meliodas we don't know when
exactly cal mario stopped being a
commandant but it is possible that he
stopped because he
transformed into an enduro I am very
curious to find out whether calm adios
or some other former member of the
commandments became the Lord's grace in
dura and I would love to know under what
circumstances this happened what drove
this high ranked demon to willingly turn
into a monster as chapter 316 unfolds
King Merlin golfer and Deanne are being
overwhelmed by the Indira and it's
thousands upon thousands of deadly spawn
the main problem that the sins are
running into while fighting this in dura
is that its spawn are spreading
everywhere extremely rapidly so the sins
cannot destroy them in a single focused
attack but if they try to use an attack
that is wide ranging in its destructive
power they could do serious damage to
the surrounding area which would include
harming innocent civilians this is where
bond comes in with his sacred treasure
curry juice we finally learned some
important things about Korra choose
including the fact that this is the
sacred treasure that is most capable of
free and erratic attacks because of its
versatility bond is able to use his
sacred treasure to unleash a barrage of
extremely fast blows that are also
highly focused and very accurate hooah
choose has an ability called super
concentration and this ability raises
the already fast and long ranging
attacks of the sacred treasure to the
highest level of accuracy using curry
juice bond is able to destroy the vast
majority of the spawn incredibly quickly
and before they can do lasting damage to
the surrounding area by using his
special attack called assault hunt bond
is able to destroy thousands of spawn in
a matter of moments but one of the spawn
manages to get away in the direction of
Leonys I will talk about how strong bond
is with his sacred treasure and how much
of a power of the sacred treasure gives
him in a little bit but first let's
discuss what else happens in the chapter
the sins begin to use teamwork in order
to battle the Endura including the use
of their special attacks like Danns
ground Gladius go Thurs black out arrow
merlyn's shock stinger Kings spear of
judgment and of course bonds assault
hunt the sins definitely appear to have
the upper hand on the end
for the time being but then the chapter
shifts focus to Leonys where one of the
spawn of the Endura is approaching the
capital Gil Thunder Hauser gree amore
and the other holy Knights are doing
their best to defeat the monster using
teamwork but it is no use as the spawn
is simply too strong
poor Gil Thunder Hauser and gree amore I
really like them as characters
especially my boy Hauser but their
strength has been so drastically
overshadowed by the sins and the demon
king in these last few arcs that they
are just completely useless at this
point they might as well just call it a
day and get yell thunders chair to take
out the ender a spawn seriously anyway
the spawn is about to kill Gill thunder
but Eska nor in his weak sunshine less
form steps up in the last moment and
blocks the spawns attack with his shield
however the shield itself isn't strong
enough to stop the attack the attack
goes through the shield and Eskin or
still ends up being injured in the
process the holy Knights are grateful to
ask him for his help but they're also
worried about his injury especially
since they know that Eskin or no longer
has possession of sunshine as Kannur
tells them that he doesn't have much
time left anyway so because the young
Knights have a bright and shining future
ahead of them
it is s canora's job as an old soldier
to protect them this is yet more
foreshadowing that s Connor may be about
to die and we've had a few such
foreshadowing moments in previous
chapters let me know what you guys think
about this is
esken or really dying or ismail going to
save him by returning sunshine to him in
the nick of time personally I think that
all of this foreshadowing about esken or
dying is just another troll by naka
Basuki he is already famous for this
type of misdirection just remember all
those so called epilogue chapters so I
think that s Kannur will end up
surviving probably because my L is going
to return the power of sunshine to him
and this power will keep him alive feel
free to let me know what you guys think
down in the comments do you agree or
disagree now let's talk about bond and
how strong he really is now that he
finally has his sacred treasure
we know that bond is no longer immortal
and we know that he possesses the
ability to use snatch which allows him
to snatch things from the
including physical objects like body
parts and organs and non-physical things
like strength and stamina while using
snatch bond gets stronger and faster
while his opponents get weaker and
slower and this is obviously an
extremely useful ability but we know
that earlier on in the story bonds body
was limited in terms of how much power
it could absorb and in terms of how long
bond could keep the power before he
starts feeling negative side effects
such as his body feeling tired and heavy
this was a clear limitation for bond
earlier on and we definitely saw this
during the battle against gallant
nevertheless after spending such a long
time in purgatory bonds body evolved the
harsh climate of purgatory kept
destroying bonds body over and over
again but because he was immortal at the
time his body kept her generating until
he built up a huge amount of resistance
and tolerance making his body extremely
strong and durable even after he stopped
being immortal by the time he left
purgatory bonds body adapted and evolved
and he was no longer negatively affected
by the harsh conditions of purgatory
which means that his body evolved beyond
anything he could have imagined before
also in purgatory bond learns to counter
the demon king special ability known as
the ruler by learning to give the demon
king some of his own strength instead of
trying to steal the demon king strength
because of the rulers ability to reverse
the effects of an attack giving the
demon king strength instead of trying to
take his away actually makes the demon
king weaker so he was forced to turn off
the ability altogether after he emerged
from purgatory bond was of course
involved in the epic battle against
demon king meliodas during this battle
we saw that bond definitely put up a
valiant fight but even though in the end
the demon king was defeated it is
important to remember that on his own
bond was not strong enough to defeat the
demon king not even after spending all
that time in purgatory bond did get the
upper hand against demon came a Liotta's
at times but this was mostly when Mele
Otis was able to gain the upper hand
against the demon king on the inside
bond was fighting the demon king on the
outside while Mele Otis was fighting him
on the inside so it wasn't just a
one-on-one battle between bond and the
demon king
whenever the demon king had the upper
hand against malleolus on the inside the
demon king proceeded to gain the upper
hand against bond on the outs
well in the end bond definitely played a
crucial role in defeating the demon king
but he needed the help of my leotis on
the inside and the other sins el dress
and even Hawke on the outside in order
to finally defeat him they all had to
work together it was definitely not a
one-on-one battle so even though bond is
now extremely powerful and I think that
he is easily the strongest sin at the
moment after meliodas of course I
believe that he still isn't at the level
of the demon king meliodas is definitely
demon king level even the demon king
himself acknowledges that meliodas is on
the level of a demon king now but bond
is not quite there yet with that said
how much of a powerup will bond received
because of finally retrieving his sacred
treasure clearly his sacred treasure is
perfectly suited for an enemy like the
Lord's grace in Deraa using his sacred
treasure bond is able to quickly deliver
a barrage of accurate blows and this
does an extremely effective job of
destroying the thousands of Enduro spawn
in a very short period of time so this
ability is clearly very useful and the
sacred treasure will enhance bonds
already impressive skills in battle but
this alone won't make him rise to the
level of the demon Kings power at least
not yet if it turns out that kurus has
additional special powers that are good
for taking on a single extremely
powerful opponent like the demon king
rather than a swarm of weaker but more
numerous opponents like the Endora spawn
that it is possible that his sacred
treasure will make him more effective in
fighting even someone like the demon
king I am obviously really glad that we
finally got to see Korra choose in
action and I am certain that this sacred
treasure will give bond a significant
boost although I think that from one we
know so far he will stop short of rising
to the demon Kings level for now we will
have to wait and see what other special
abilities bond sacred treasure might
actually have but if Cora chews can
amplify bonds ability to transfer his
own energy into others then he could
potentially use his own strength to help
boost meliodas power just enough to take
out the demon king once and for all
alternatively if demon king zelgius
decides to use his ability the ruler at
any point in the future and bond decides
to give the demon king a huge influx of
energy in that very moment that energy
could actually strike a really important
blow against the demon
King because of the rulers ability which
reverses the effects of attacks I can't
wait to see how these two epic battles
pan out the battle against the Indira
and the battle between demon king
zelgius and Mellie Otis and Elizabeth
I'm also very curious to see what will
ultimately happen - Eska Noir
right now it doesn't look too good for
him but I have faith in my L will show
up and save s canora's life most likely
by allowing s Kannur to take possession
of sunshine once again let me know what
you guys think what do you think of bond
sacred treasure and how much of a
powerup do you think the sacred treasure
will give him also do you believe that
kuru chuse has any additional special
abilities other than what we've seen so
far let me know down in the comments I
always love hearing from you if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more you can leave a like to let me know
and if you're new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell be sure to check us
out on twitter and instagram at anime
outpour for all the latest 7 Deadly Sins
news and updates also don't forget to
check out our brand new bond love the
pain and Eskin or all hail Diwan shirts
on anime out Broadcom a huge thank you
to all of our anime uproar patrons for
supporting our work I want to give a
special thank you to our pro hero to
your patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh chops is the man nothing but a
fan and Jason Wilson and another huge
thank you to our the one tier patrons
the ones who stand above all other clans
including baby Rey ace
Ingrid ah a Lola nod of Maddy Mac and
Michael Calderon if you guys feel that
our content provides value for you and
you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
up for patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it and until next time
see our space cowboys
[Music]